Drake
uh just
I was just trying to get out there I
mean I left New York the day after and
I've been in Phoenix since then so just
try to get uh comfortable where I was
gonna be
[Music]
like
uh
oh
um
Brianna Stewart John Quail Jones
Sabrina and and uh
and
[Music]
um
vandersloot
Seattle
Sonics
yeah I feel like I can be asked to do a
multitude of things so just got to be
prepared for you know try to build my
game up to be versatile and
um you know so whatever coach needs me
to do I'm willing to do
um
there's a lot of players that inspire me
but I just I think that 03 class of like
mellow Brian uh um D Wade
um I was a freshman in high school when
they came out so that was a significant
time in my life and I looked up to those
guys a lot
um yeah just yeah just I want to compete
harder against them you know because I
followed him for so long I wanted to
show improve and gain that respect from
them so I felt like I did that
well winning the championship in uh 2017
and 2018.
I I just I I just think that's the
narratives that come with I don't think
people watch the Phoenix Suns enough to
say that you know you know we got a
couple guys back in this trade but also
science Terence Ross as well so
um I I once our team gets hold we'll
figure out where we are and see see what
needs the hose needs to be plugged in
but the easy things to say right now we
don't have a bench
uh I love America I love where I come
from I love what I love that the game is
you know it brought me so much afforded
me so much so I try to represent
everybody I grew up with and everybody
in our country so yeah it's important to
me and I don't know I don't know I
haven't thought about too much of it
this summer and we'll see we'll see what
happens though
oh yeah most definitely I think he I
think he still has the talent to play in
our league
[Applause]
say it again
uh
probably jaw right now he probably got
the best one
uh Drake Beyonce Rihanna
what you got what you got Jose
bro
I'm sick I'm bad I gotta deal with you
you say it again
uh I I wanna I wouldn't I wouldn't tell
you
uh if you're locked in enough
um it can happen pretty fast you've got
veteran players that know how to play
the game and no different terminology so
I think you know we put our mind to it
it can happen pretty quickly
um
um probably my first one
uh yeah
um I want to reach Perfection you know I
know I'll never reach it but I guess
just trying to get there every day is is
good enough
um you know I feel like in a competition
with myself just trying to be the best
version of me every day sometimes you
don't reach that but you know it's it's
fun competing with yourself that way
I can't hear you said again
uh Ransom 38 Special Drake
come on bro
huh
well you see already a last game they
played together they lost but um they
were down 20 and fourth quarter they
both came out there and you know Kyrie
had 26 in the fourth and Luke had some
big shots so it's gonna be like that
it's gonna be tough to guard them
best trash talker
um
probably debug but I haven't really got
on the court right to see to hear all
the little stuff they saying but from
playing against them deep deep book
probably is the best
Deandre ayton
yeah yeah
I mean size always matters in our game
and I feel like all the biggest teams
had an advantage and yeah you're
starting to see more teams
from this from the point guard down to
their center six six to you know seven
feet to the center you know so I I just
think just a couple more ground you need
more athletic and bigger guys and the
skill level has gone up in our league so
you need more size too so it's all it's
all good for the game I think
[Music]
the league oh the game of basketball has
taught me discipline and dedication hard
work and
um that's pretty much all I can say
no
no I ain't even thinking about the
off-season there's a lot that goes into
that and no I'm not even thinking about
that it's not even on my radar
yeah
I would call Brandon Ingram Young no
more but I feel like we got the same
body types and we score from the same
areas of the floor um
um I would say him but I want to call
him Young no more I feel like he's a vet
in the league now um
I don't know I think we all got our own
unique in different games now I feel
like there's a lot of skill players that
bring in their own twist to the game so
I wouldn't I wouldn't say anybody
tank to because that's what it matters
I just love to play
the playoffs is the most important part
of the Season you know I think all great
players enjoy the playoffs so
um I feel like that's when you really
come alive is when at those moments you
know arise you know as you get later in
the playoffs
nah just do the same stuff you know just
keep working the same way
um nothing extra
say it again
oh yeah most definitely you bring myself
over here Kyrie over here you got a lot
of trades or small pieces that help
you know Trey Murphy over here
interrogate me right now what's up
brother
uh I'm gonna go with you don't
disappoint me bro all right I got you
guys IQ for the game I think it's um
yeah enthusiasm for the game I think
that goes under rated CP really loves
ball you know he's just like watching
the game like analyzing
um like going through strategy and stuff
so I've been in a been a week there now
a couple practices a few games and he
always pulled me to the side and we just
talking hoop you know so I love that
about him and
um you know but obviously on the floor
he can create so much for his teammates
and for himself is only going to help us
I don't remember getting picked last
ever
yes yes times you play you wanted to
play with the older guys and they
wouldn't let you play and and you know
and you just you know everybody heard
that story before and you just want to
get out there and prove yourself
um but yeah I mean in this setting like
you being picked last really is not
saying like you wanted to you know it's
still one of the it's like the richest
million I mean the broke his millionaire
getting picked I seen that on Twitter
somebody said the last pick is like the
broke his millionaire so yeah it don't
matter man I guess as long as you're out
there on the floor
say what
uh seven was retired in Phoenix I wanted
to keep seven but Kevin Johnson is such
a great player that he got it up in a
rafter so the only other number I know
is 35.
start my phone bench my
um game and cut my laptop
2K
yeah the new war zone map just dropped
the the research and so I'm gonna check
that out too
uh I haven't no probably not probably
not
dirt
on
enjoy the moment enjoy the moment
everything's gonna happen pretty fast
yeah I do I had enough of Dave on the
sideline asking questions in the virtual
world so yeah of course I skip it
um a lot of Ransom and 38 special that's
about it
ah means a lot I mean
um I always want to be respected by the
grace in the game for my for my game and
my abilities and you know that says it
all right there you know so I get love
from the greats wherever I see them
especially in this weekend it's good to
see all the former NBA players and
current NBA players and it's just
nothing but love and respect that you
know it shows so
um that that means the world to me that
I'm amongst those you know I can get
close to the top ten
um my mom
appreciate that
brizz explain that
all High play I am a 10.
that's a lot of threats in the west
um
yeah I mean it's a lot of I feel like
it's you never know who can go off and
win the West with so many deep teams you
know from one to eight well one to ten
it's a lot of deep teams so we'll see
just grateful you know just it's a we
put a lot of work into those shoes it's
a big representation of who I am as a
person so for somebody to be
representing me like that it feels
pretty cool
nah not in hell no no that's some